OK. This is big news. I told you yesterday
that today we would have new polling. That
was. Done at least partially after Donald
Trump tested positive for Corona virus.
We have our first such poll. And the bottom
appears to have completely dropped out for
Donald Trump in a new CNN poll. Joe Biden is
leading Donald Trump by 16 points, 57 to 41
among likely voters. Some of the recent big
lead polls have been registered voter polls,
likely voter polls this close to the election
considered more accurate. And indeed,
this is the worst poll for Trump of the entire
campaign. Now, to be as cautious as we can,
OK, this poll has a margin of error of three
point six. This means that the results could be
as close as an eight point eight point lead.
If you account for the largest margin of error
in the most favorable way possible to Trump,
imagine that Joe Biden's 57 is really only
fifty three point four. Imagine that Trump's 41
is really forty four point six. That gives us a
margin minimum of eight point eight. And that is
basically where the national average now is. If
you look at the national average of recent polls,
Joe Biden leads by an average of nine point two
points. Now, as a brief reminder, before I get
into all of my caveats and we've got to vote rant,
you know, prepare yourselves for that. If we
look back at 2016 on this day, October 6th,
on October six, 2016, Hillary Clinton's lead over
Donald Trump was four point one. OK. So today,
Joe Biden's lead over Trump is 124 percent larger
than Hillary's was on this days in 2016. Now,
think back to yesterday. If we looked at October
5th this year versus October 5th, four years ago,
Joe Biden's lead yesterday was one hundred
and seven percent bigger than Hillary's on
this day, on that day in 2016. We are now 24 hours
later. And thanks to two new polls, Joe Biden's
lead is now 124 percent larger than Hillary's
on this day in 2016. Now, what does this mean?
Oh, wait. What does this mean?
You all know we have to vote, this means
nothing other than we have to vote. Plus 16 in
October when the polls are expected to tighten. It
is stunning, but we have to vote. Nate Silver from
538, in fact, issuing a word of caution, tweeting
this morning about the new poll that, quote, It's
good that pollsters are publishing these results
instead of sitting on them. And this is one of
those times when a large movement in the race
is plausible. But we have a lot of polling at it
most. And I think he means and it mostly suggests
more modest gains for Joe Biden. We have the
opportunity to make a historic repudiation of
Donald Trump a reality. It's only an opportunity
right now. We're going to talk about states in
which early voting has started and is starting
yesterday. Today, tomorrow. Next Monday,
we have the opportunity to actually make this the
biggest landslide since Reagan in the 80s. Or we
have the possibility of being utterly devastated
that we are going to have another four years of
this and we will know about that maybe November
3rd, very late, maybe November 4th or 5th. Let's
actually make it happen. And you know what? One
of the great reasons to make it happen is I want
a stronger economy. And one of the things we know
is that the economy does far better when there's a
Democratic president. A new report says exactly
that. And we're going to talk about that next.